the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
so the question is we have the string s
is the string 600 is six triple one and
six triple two so we're going to create
this string here right it's initially an
empty string I want to mention that the
plus equals for example if I say a plus
equals one this is equivalent to a is
equal to a plus one okay we've seen this
a couple times before last lecture in
the lecture before that so all this
means here this line here is we're going
to take the previous string that we have
and we're just going to add it to itself
plus the last letter so the first thing
we're going to have is going to be new
underscore STR is equal to two then this
line here is going to say now I'm going
to add to the two the two that I already
have the element at position zero which
is a six so I'm going to have six then
I'm going to add to that the element at
position at index 4 so I'm starting to
count from zero so this is zero one two
three four right so that's a space and
I'm going to go notice I have four and
then nothing in the middle
so my stop is going to be length s by
default and I'm going to take every 30
characters now every 30 is longer than
the actual string I have right so we're
just going to end at the end of the
string so this is the next thing that
we're going to add is a space okay and
then the last thing we're doing here is
we're starting at 13 so now I'm going to
have to count 13 0 1 2 3 4 5 6 8 9 10 11
12 13 that's the one I'm going to go
backward because of this minus one
and I'm going to go backward until 10
but right before 10 okay so one less
than 10 so I'm going to do 100 so this
one the zero and then this year okay and
I'm going to print this new string I
think this is right if you paste it into
spider it should give you 26 space 100
so I think most of the class got it
right yes perfect